نبدا اولا اذا مع من مدينه باخمه شرقيه
اوكرانيا حيث اعلن يفجان بريغو جين مؤسس
ميليشيا فاجنر سيطره قواته على كامل
المدينه بينما نفت القوات الاوكرانيه
اعلان بريجوجن وقالت انها لا تزال تسيطر
على جنوب غرب باخمت للحديث عن هذه
التطورات ينضم الينا مراسلوا الجزيره امين
درغامي من موسكو
حسان مسعود من ثياب وتامر الصمادي من
ميكوليف جنوبي اوكرانيا وسنبدا معك حسان
مسعود في كييف وصدى هذا الاعلان اعلان
على كامل لدى السلطات الاوكرانيه
نعم مارسي وابدا من اخر التصريحات واحدث
التصريحات الرسميه من الجانب الاوكراني
الذي جاء على لسان نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان مليار التي قالت بتصريحا
مقتضب على صفحتها عبر تيليجرام ان الوضع
في باخمت حرج وان القتال ما زال مستمرا
هناك
واكدت على ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
في منطقه تقع جنوب غربي منطقه باخموت
وانها تسيطر على عدد من المصانع والمنشات
الخاصه وفق تعبيرها هذا يعني ان الجانب
الاوكراني حتى هذه اللحظه وان كان يعترف
بشكل واضح
وبشكل صريح بان الوضع في بخموت حرج وهو ما
يشبه ما كانت تعبر عنه هذه المسؤوله التي
كانت معنيه بشكل واضح خلال الفتره الاخيره
بتفاصيل
بان الوضع حرج للغايه وان الوضع هناك صعب
وان المعارك ضاريه بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه اليوم تقول ان الوضع حرج وان
القوات الاوكرانيه هم في منطقه تقع في اخر
منطقه باخموت من الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه
وانها فقط حتى هذه اللحظه وفق المعطيات
التي ادلت بها في منطقه صناعيه وفي ما
زالت تسيطر على عدد من المناطق والقطاعات
هذا ان كان يشير الى الوضع هناك لكنه في
ذات الوقت ايضا يشير الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ربما تراجعت وان هناك تقدما
روسيا في منطقه باخموت يضافوا الى ذلك قبل
قليل ايضا استطعنا ان نطلع سريعا على
الخارطه الشهيره هنا في اوكرانيا والتي
تعتمد من قبل كافه المسؤولين والمراقبين
للاوضاع في اوكرانيا ولتحركات القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه على الجبهات
وهو هذا الموقع الذي يتم من خلاله كشف
مواقع القوات الروسيه على الجبهات يظهر
تقدما واضحا بينما كان عليه الوضع خلال
اليوم الماضي وبينما هو عليه الوضع الان
في ضخمه لصالح الجانب الروسي باتت الخارطه
في ما يتعلق بمدينه باخمه التحديدا نتحدث
فقط عن المدينه وليس منطقه باخموت هذه
المدينه ماتت الخارطه تميل الى اللون
الاحمر الذي يعني القوات الروسيه التي
باتت تتقدم في منطقه بخمت وفق المعطيات
الاوليه ولكن وفق ما اعتدنا عليه في الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ما جرى سابقا هذا لا
يعني بشكل كامل السيطره الروسيه على منطقه
ولا الانسحاب الاوكراني من باخمت الا اذا
جرى هناك اعلان رسمي من الجانب الاوكراني
بالانسحابي من منطقه باخموت انتقل الى
تامر الصمادي في ميكولايف تامر استمعنا
الى الجانب السياسي من رده الفاعل على ما
اعلن بشان ضخمه ماذا عن الانباء الاتيه من
الميدان كيف انعكس كل ذلك في الميدان
الانباء الوارده من الميدان ال سي تؤكد
بان القوات الاوكرانيه لازالت تقاتل وان
هنالك معارك شوارع ضاريه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه في مناطق متعدده من
باخموت المتحدث باسم القياده الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه يتحدث عن استعار المواجهه وعن
سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه حتى هذه اللحظه
وهذه التصريحات كانت قبل ساعه من الان
كانت تشير الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تسيطر على جنوب غرب المدينه وانها
تقاتل بشراسه هناك للحفاظ على مواقعها
وكان يتحدث
المتحدث باسم القياده الشرقيه عن خسائر في
صفوف القوات الروسيه وقوات باجنر تحدث عن
اكثر من 200 قتيل وجريح في صفوف تلك
القوات وتحدث عن تدمير اكثر من عشره
مستودعات للذخيره في المدينه وكانت
اوكرانيه بثت مقطعا مصوره لعمليات القتال
صباح هذا اليوم وقالت بان ما تم بثه من
صور طيله الفتره الماضيه وحتى هذا اليويو
اليوم لا يعكس الواقع الذي تشهده من حرب
دروس بين الطرفين وان القوات الاوكرانيه
تلقي بكل ثقلها وراء هذه الجبهه للتمسك
بمواقعها هذا ما اشار اليه المتحدث باسم
القياده الشرقيه الاوكرانيه لكن في
الحقيقه انسي الغريب في هذه الاثناء
واللافت ان صح التعبير في هذا الوقت
بالذات في وقت الحديث عن باخمت هو الحديث
عن الجبهه الاخرى هنا في خرسون جنوبي
البلاد قبل قليل ظهر حاكم خيرسون
الاوكراني ليصدر
بفيديو مصور ليتحدث بشكل شبه رسمي ان صح
التعبير انجاز لنا ان نقول ذلك عن بدء
الهجوم المضاد بشكل او اقتراب الهجوم
المضاد بشكل
يعني رسمي في المناطق الجنوبيه لا سيما في
خيرسون هو
ظهر امام عدسه
الكاميرات في المدينه ليقول بان رئيس
اوكرانيا اعطى الامر بالدخول في هذا
الهجوم والتصدي للقوات الروسيه واستعاده
الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
في خرسون
وجبروجا وهو يقول ايضا نهايه بان
الخطوات الاخيره والتجهيزات الاخيره باتت
قاب قوسين او ادنى بالحديث والعوده الى
باق موت المتحدث باسم القياده الشرقيه كما
اشرت تحدث عن استمرار القتال وقال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت موجوده هناك لا
سيما في مناطق جنوب الغرب نتابع ابرز ماقل
تبقى بخموت الهدف الرئيسي المعتمده
للمعتدين في المدينه تبقى المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه تحت سيطرتنا اننا نصب
محاولات العدو الهجوميه هناك القتال مستمر
ايضا باتجاه لمن ومارينكا